oh
il s'élève sur les hauteurs de ammann a
un petit village du mont-liban son
visage bienveillance dépendant le ciel
surplombant beyrouth et la mer
méditerranée
sacha rebelles est l'un des premiers
saints libanais et c'est à lui que bien
des malades s'adresse selon la croyance
il aurait le pouvoir de guérison
au liban on ne plaisante pas avec saint
charbel ce qu'un jeune homme a appris à
ses dépens
d'harcourt à la facebook charbel khoury
ne se doutait pas qu'une blague publié
sur sa page facebook se moquant d'un
supposé miracles de saint charbel lui
vaudrait la foudre de certains libanais
une convocation chez les enquêteurs de
la cybercriminalité du liban alfie
winehouse thomas canada il a été victime
d'une campagne de harcèlement et de
menaces
louis et une autre personne qui avait
commenté ce blague menaces de viol pour
la fille violent pour sa famille
l'adresse de la fis a été publié en
ligne en disant allez en haut
allez vous venger ce réel des menaces de
mort il a été molesté dans son travail
et est arrivé à un moment il a été
convoqué au bureau de la lutte contre la
cybercriminalité le laos coup ça m'a
choqué emma intervenait en tant que
défenseur droits de l'homme
c'est que il a été lui interpellé lui
qui au moins une victime de harcèlement
et non les gens qui l'ont harcelée
pourquoi c'est le porte parole du centre
catholique d'information du liban qui a
déposé la plainte contre charbel kfoury
s'ils n'appliquent pas les propos
menaçants que certains ont tenu à
l'égard du jeune homme il s'agit pour
lui de liberté d'expression ça n'arrive
pas à exécuter ces menaces
jamais un chrétien fait
il fait des menaces mais sage est ici
cela seul à devoir d'exprimer cette
liberté d'expression ne s'étant pas
jusqu'à faire de l'humour sur le dos
d'un saint vous avez la liberté de dire
qu'est ce que tu veux mais vous ne vais
pas la liberté d'insulter les gens
d'insulter les religions d'insulter des
cinq continents ont obligé à enlever son
poste j'ai repoussé son casque
c'est en guise de protestation et de
soutien au jeune homme que wadi al asmar
du centre libanais des droits humains
s'est empressé de republier la blague et
les menaces qui ont suivi sur sa propre
page facebook
alors que charbel goury lui se voyait
forcé par les enquêteurs de tout effacer
et il a été obligé par une décision du
procureur de ne pas s'enregistrer sur
facebook pendant un mois ce qui prouve à
mon avis c'est une des premières
décisions de cette nature au liban wadi
al asmar accusent l'église d'avoir usé
de son influence sur l'actuel président
michel aoun pour forcer la justice à
intervenir
je vous assure aucun influence
le défenseur des droits et libertés se
retrouve aujourd'hui lui même devant la
justice son cas a été référée à la cour
pénale
c'est une histoire qui de moins en moins
inusité au liban largement considéré
comme un des rares pays de droit au
moyen orient
les interpellations la censure les actes
d'intimidation et les restrictions
deviennent plus fréquents de passe très
difficile depuis deux ans la répression
est en hausse au liban alors que la
liberté d'expression et la liberté de la
presse accusant un recul
me ak oui nous avons répertorié pas
moins de 35 violation du genre contre
les intellectuels des journalistes et
des activistes ce genre d'intimidation
ne surgit pas de nulle part
c'est une stratégie politique pour faire
craindre aux gens la liberté
l'érosion graduelle de l'espace de
liberté s'accélère rapportent des ong
comme amnesty international et human
rights watch alors que le liban classé
parmi les 42 pays les plus corrompus
selon transparency international est
toujours sans gouvernement et qu'il est
en proie à des crises et des paralysies
ces institutions répétition minutes au
20h de ce colloque
jat chahrour décrit la situation comme
une guerre qui est loin d'être gagnée
contre les défenseurs de la liberté une
classe politique qui se comporte de plus
en plus comme à l'époque de l'occupation
du liban par la syrie
si tout utilisateur de facebook twitter
ou qu'ils soient journalistes activistes
écrivains ou simples citoyens interrogés
ou arrêtés pour avoir exprimé une
opinion contre le gouvernement outre la
présidence nous sommes en territoire
inconnu non moins de comparer avec 2005
quand le régime syrien contrôler le
liban à mon avis il y aurait les moyens
militaires de faire comme d'âge des
freerolls à wadi al asmar aussi se
perçoit comme un combattant dans les
tranchées il a l'habitude de se frotter
aux dirigeants libanais
forces de l'ordre membre fondateur d'un
collectif baptisé tu es mis sur pied en
pleine crise des déchets au liban il
pointe le phénomène dépasse de loin on
tiers du liban les médias sociaux ont un
peu chamboulé bousculer toutes les
normes de contrôle de la population
c'est à dire que les régimes
autoritaires ou moins autoritaire
avaient leurs mécanismes de contrôle par
les télés par les médias principaux par
les journalistes le politique quand il a
peur malheureusement au lieu d'essayer
de comprendre les raisons
ils oppriment et ça c'est internationale
c'est universel